What's up guys welcome back. I'm hanging again with my good friend Brian brushwood. He is the Modern road. Hey, man
This is Grant thompson. He's the king of random. And today we're playing with some mad science. We've got some drain cleaner
We've got some aluminum foil. What kind of a reaction will they produce if we mix the two together?
Why do we have pink balloons? now this chemical drain cleaner
We picked up just came from the local hardware store, and this is not liquid
This is the crystal flakes and if you open it up, you'll see it's actually dry says, "Contains sodium hydroxide"
That's a little terrifying. Alright, so before we even began you shredded a bunch of this aluminum using a paper shredder
What's the point of doing that? So we did; we got a shredder we put aluminum foil through it and thats treads it up into
Little tiny pieces, the purpose of doing that is to increase the surface area of the aluminum
It's gonna make our reaction happen a little bit faster. Oh Commander Worf, You look amazing. That's so cool. We got our shredded aluminum
We've got our drain cleaner all we need now is a little bit of water Oh, we got a little bit of water
So we are ready to rock. Now when you're dealing with chemical reactions
It's not a bad idea to start a little bit smaller and work our way up
So we're gonna start off with this small glass bottle here
And if everything goes to plan we can move our way up to one of these things. Alright
so here's what we want to do. Start off by putting a little bit of your drain cleaner, your sodium
Hydroxide, into a glass jar, So now we can put in a little bit of our aluminum
Foil scraps on top and I don't notice I'd say about four times the volume of aluminum
What chemical reaction are we hoping is about to happen? Because right now
We've got what lye and aluminum
Right so, lye is Sodium Hydroxide (NaOH) and the aluminum is basically just aluminum metal (AL)
What we're gonna do is mix in some water, and as we do that the sodium hydroxide is going to dissolve
And it's gonna react with the aluminum and release hydrogen gas. Right.
And that gas that's being released is the stuff that we're after, and that's why we've got pink balloons
[I'm feeling ya, i'm feeling ya. ] So we will start off trying to put a little bit of water in the balloon, so stretch the mouth of your
Balloon over your water bottle got it turn it upside down. [yeah], and put a reasonable amount in there
It's not gonna hurt us to have more, rather than less. [Right around there?] That looks perfect
We're gonna fit that over top of the jar now
And once that is secured you can do the balloon. [Are you ready?] Yep, and it's gonna let the water in
Boom there goes the water, now watch what happens.
Wow, that's a lot of water
But you see as the sodium hydroxide dissolves, it reacts with the aluminum and releases hydrogen gas; so all those little bubbles that you're seeing
right now, are hydrogen, and here's the cool thing give it a little shake and
Here to see that reaction accelerates dramatically. Oh, this is my favorite part
Congratulation
Whoa dude check this out! [holy cow holy cow! ] It's going crazy. It's like pumping up. How does that bottle feel now? It's really hot
it's really really hot that balloon is getting huge how much pressure can take I don't know I think I think we're hey we
Got a little bit more, but I mean it's it's about to burst okay
So update guys this reaction just took off after about two minutes to and crazy
It's hot so hot go ahead pull the balloon off. Don't spell
oh
The shame smell all that hydrogen that we just lost
R.I.P Hydrogen gas
thats the smell of failure
Burned my finger tips that was insanely hot okay?
Well here, take a look at this feel that oh yeah, that is that is really work
so
It took about two minutes to small bubbling and then that reaction just took off in an instant that blew and blew up really crazy
So we got to do that again?
Well did the big one?
Will be careful well let's let's get a good first reaction with this one
That can't be good. That is awesome. I love it. Okay
So when you stuff that down the reaction just went crazy, right?
Yeah, cuz I put the aluminum back down in there there. We go okay, [and] then we want to get that reacting against
We're gonna need to push that back down here
I think we can just kind of wash like we can put it right into the balloon look at that
There we go
[okay], yeah look how fast that reacts wow dude. Oh, it's amazing. You're going dude
That's fill up fast what we got in this balloon
Hopefully is hydrogen gas right?
And we can verify that just by dumping a little bit of dish soap to a bowl of water
We don't have as much to work with due to our
all right preview this Op attend an dling [idea] and if we put the neck of the balloon in there and fill it up and
Slowly let go we should start to generate some bubbles
whoa, whoa
So cool guys. We are confirmed. We have hydrogen gas okay. Let's take this up to 11. Let's crank it up
We are super stoked this idea works. We got hydrogen
So we're gonna supersize it now with a one gallon juice container a lot more lie in these balloons
I got out of truck stuff. You're talking about these things right here
Rook stops they have balloons. All right here we go
So I'm gonna start off by just pouring a lot more lying there
It seems like [you] really can't have too much. I would think you could what's going to throw a few handfuls of?
And we've got our truck stop balloons standing by I have to find a way to hold that on tightly though
I don't know why they roll these balloons up. That's a little bit
Hey slippery, so it looks from our last reaction like we got about two minutes before it starts going crazy
Yeah, but you can tell it's already at least starting right now. You see a problem. Yeah
Now this is awesome guys
It's only about 30 seconds, and I already feel the bottom of the glass containers starting to warm up
You can see the water's gone completely clouded with bubbles
I was starting to get a slight indication in our balloon that we're collecting some gas
So I guess really it's just a matter of time because it really did it took two full minutes before the reaction went to high
Gear yeah, and then it just went crazy at that point so here
We're definitely collecting some gas as you can see our balloons filling up. You know what I bet
We filled this one up, and I bet [we] could tie it off and then get another one going. Oh my gosh
Oh my gosh guys check this out. [it's] going crazy
It's actually getting really hot the glasses getting hut the balloon is filling up with really hot oh my gosh
Oh, that's two dead. Tell me this is safe. That is amazing here. Let me get another. I'm getting another balloon
Alright, so this reaction is going great
Already filled up one balloon, and we have a little bit
Actually, we still have quite a bit of gas, but it looks like the reaction settling down. Well. It's real good
Look at that. That is crazy fast this reaction is exothermic it releases heat as it
Reacts with the aluminum, and you can definitely feel that this glass is so
Ridiculously warm right out. How does that feel right now, bra? Oh much better now it feels tolerable
I was afraid that thing was gonna bust open yeah second there
I was amazing so here's the next question if I put a straw into this balloon and slowly let the gas out if I light
The tip will it keep burning like a torch or the whole thing blow up in my face
whoa
Hydrogen Torch guys. It's Melly Gonna try this first phasing look at that, whoa
Like a little sodium hydroxide in the morning. Oh that was amazing. It was incredible. That was a fun experiment
I'm really glad that we tried that today now we had another cool idea
What if we took this inside where you can see the flames a little bit better? Oh, it's warm that might be steamed. Oh
That was super fast
[whew] nice, wow dude that's amazing wow
Supercool guys so now you know what happens if you mix crystal drain cleaner with aluminum foil and water yeah
You get an awesome torch, and you get some nasty slurry. How do you dispose of this stuff?
So what we're [going] [to] do is dump this in a solution of vinegar because that's going to help neutralize the base
But remember [guys] you are playing with very caustic chemicals these are very dangerous
They have very strong warning labels
So if you think about doing any kind of experiments like this make sure you read the warning labels
They're there for a reason so guys if you haven't already go check out my friend Brian Brushwood his links in the description
He's the modern rug
Yeah, man, check it out me and Jason Murphy are on a quest to become [the] ultimate warrior gentlemen and Scoundrel
You're gonna dig it and us for all of you
Thanks so much for joining us for this experiment will see in the next one. Talk to you that
Brian get off your phone. Let's get back to work, right?
That was a super fast no, please note. That was scary his industrial-strength Trucker balloons are amazing
you